the deadly flu epidemic is taking a toll
on the nation's workforce more than
17,000 flu-related hospitalizations have
been reported in the US since October
three-year-old Olivia Villu died
yesterday in Indiana after testing
positive for influenza vladimir duthiers
of our streaming network cbsn is here
vlad good morning good morning federal
health officials are urging those sick
with the flu to stay home from work or
school and while that recommendation is
critical to helping prevent the flu
spread it is estimated to cost
businesses across the country billions
of dollars my kids got sick I got sick
my parents got sick some sort of family
business it it really we just closed
down for a week after five of its seven
employees called out sick last month
Sherry's show claw art in Kalamazoo
Michigan had to temporarily shut its
doors that immediately impacted the
stores bottom line says manager Ashley
Rafferty huge amount of profit loss and
then employees not getting paid that
affected them to employee consulting
firm Challenger gray and Christmas
estimates this season the virus could
cause about 25 million employees to miss
at least four eight-hour shifts the
study projects that could cost the US
economy more than twenty 1 billion
dollars in lost productivity but sick
employees aren't all to blame sick
children and school closures are another
reason workers are staying home this
season more than 40 school districts in
at least 13 states have closed because
of the flu many in an effort to
eliminate any trace of the virus she
just had a heart for teaching in a heart
for students that's how Lindsay foster
remembers 38 year-old Heather Holland
the second grade teacher from Texas died
last week from complications with the
flu she truly cared about the kids she
came in contact with one of Holland's
former students is Foster's daughter now
16 year old Mary grace I think I would
describe mrs. hall and as somebody who
really really tried really really hard
with me through everything it wasn't
just my child that she was that kind of
teacher for she just had a heart for
teaching in a heart for students
Holland's husband told a local Texas
newspaper that she planned to pick
flu medication but felt the 116 dollar
copay was just too high after finding
that out he reportedly bought the
prescription a week later by that point
his wife's symptoms had quickly begun
deteriorating that story yeah another
reminder how important it is to take it
very seriously and stay home yes well if
you feel that you have it it was very
quickly in some cases Thank You Vlad